the top 1% in America the richest
country in the world makes 650,000 a
year lot of money but every kid that's
19's like if you tell him well you're
only going to make a million of year
they're like damn I suck they think it's
like so easy it's impossible YouTube
influencer money that's right most genz
are like dude I can't even afford a
house now our lack of patience of eating
for a period of time to get to
where we want to get to is Gone Gone
Gone the reason so many people were able
to make it was you thought that it would
take 15 years for you to make it now you
tell someone who's 21 it's going to take
15 days to make it way and they're like
nah man I ain't got that time like bro
all you got is time popular culture the
people because Mark Zuckerberg could in
seven years because of the internet get
to a tril everyone's like yo you know